as a producer and a director what advice
can you give to authors on it suppose
somebody sets out to write a romance
novel but they know at some point they'd
love to have it adapted so what advice
can you give because I know you'd said
earlier that sometimes things are too
heady or it's in someone's mind and you
can't really portray that what advice
could I give for an author mm-hmm to
adapt a book um we're starting out sorry
I'm yeah should make myself more clear
just starting out to write a novel but
with hopes to maybe have it adapted
later
I think the number one thing for us is
making sure that there's enough story in
the book so a lot of novels romance
novels are written when it's just the
two people that are connecting and it's
all about them and we don't know much
about their outside lives and or any
kind of influences or have a story that
goes around it as well and so that's
where it becomes difficult to adapt so
we need story okay interesting so so and
then more visuals it sounds like then
then sort of this internal no we can
create the visuals the the problem with
too much internal dialogue in a book and
then trying to adapt it into a movie is
that if that's the only thing that's
driving the book then we have a hard
time adapting a movie but otherwise
almost all these novels have internal
dialogue and we use a lot of it what we
did funnier in matchmakers playbook
which it's a great story but so much of
it happens in our main character's head
and so we had difficulty initially
coming up with a way of how we were
going to portray this on screen because
if we only use the words that he says
the dialogue that's in the book he comes
out as such a big but no one is
ever gonna like him
when you read the book he is delightful
and hilarious because he you can you
basically are reading his mind so we
thought okay well how can we take that
really awesome character and put him on
screen without making him sound like a
total because he's only saying
certain things and so we decided to
break the fourth wall and do voiceover
so this
entire movie is gonna be the character
our main character looking into camera
and saying and that's how I do it and
that ultimately will allow our audience
to connect with him and love him so that
while he's saying out and be seeing
these things we can read his
mind no he's not a bad guy we know he's
out of his mind
so in that regard in that specific
instance we were able to take the
internal dialogue and and translate it
onto the screen because we were doing it
in a the in film language we can change
the zone language to it to to adjust to
his personality but that's very that's
very unusual and it's not gonna work for
everything and so it worked for
matchmakers because it's a comedy so so
when we have others we need we need
there to be a little bit more of a story
that we can follow these characters on
we want to see these these characters we
want to see these characters do things
that are interesting and fall in love
and a little bit of a naughty scene
throwing well you know three naughty
you